Speaker 1: Let's go next to Michael from Scranton.
Michael from Scranton, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hi. Um, I was wondering,
uh, okay, I just forgot my question.
Sorry for swearing and. Bye.
Speaker 1: All right. Goodbye. There
is Michael from Scranton with a very, very
strong appearance on the David Pakman show,
which we love to see. Let's go to Magnus from
Sweden. From Sweden? Magnus from Sweden. I
don't know that you could have a more perfect
call than the last one, but let's try Magnus.
Speaker 4: Hello, David. Sir.
Greetings from Sweden. Can you.
Speaker 1: Hear me? I can hear you fine.
Speaker 4: Great. Excellent. Just one
question. If my daughter again would be Donald
Trump's V.P. candidate for the 2024 election. Do
you think this could benefit the Democrats
even further to allow to vote even more?
Speaker 1: Sorry if. What was the first thing?
Speaker 4: If what if if, by the way, Taylor
GREENE would be Donald Trump's V.P.? Kind of.
Speaker 1: Oh, Mark Ruffalo. Oh, yeah. Would it
benefit Democrats? I you know, my opinion
might be different in 2024. Right now.
I believe Marjorie Taylor GREENE is Trump's
running mate would further make obvious that
the entire MAGA movement is overtly a joke, like
it's always been a joke, but it's now overtly
a joke. Trump doesn't leave his house. He gives
weird interviews and records, these strange videos
and whatever. Now, what could change? My opinion
is that Marjorie Taylor GREENE is now distancing
herself from the crazy magazines and trying to
align with the slightly less crazy magazine.
She's denouncing Lauren Boebert, and she wants
to be alongside Kevin McCarthy. So if Marjorie
Taylor GREENE successfully aligns herself with the
slightly less crazy part of the Republican Party,
maybe her being Trump's VP would be
helpful to him. But if it were today,
I think GREENE hurts Trump as a running mate.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I also think it would be a
rather terrifying thought if my lawyer, Taylor
GREENE, would be wise president and even worse,
president of the United States
in saying what happened to Trump?
Speaker 1: If Trump is president at age
78 and Marjorie Taylor GREENE is the VP,
that's a very scary situation. I agree with you.
Speaker 4: Oh, I also saw curiosity. I know
you've been to Denmark many times,
but have you ever been to Sweden?
Speaker 1: I've been to Denmark only once. I
have never been to Sweden. I was destined to go
to Sweden at the start of the pandemic. And then
we all know what happened. And now it is very,
very high on my list. I would love to get
to Sweden. I think I'd prefer to go in late
spring or something like that, maybe early
summer. But I would absolutely love to go.
Speaker 4: You're welcome to visit us anytime.
Speaker 1: Do you guys have that? What what's what
are the dishes that Sweden is most known for?
Speaker 4: I it'll probably be very
traditional Swedish meatballs and mashed
potatoes. And the legal jam, of course.
Speaker 1: Right. And is it
better in Sweden than at IKEA?
Speaker 2: Well, I.
Speaker 4: Think it
would be rather authentic. Okay.
Yes. So I think you're fine. Yeah,
I've tasted them in other countries. Yeah, they
are just about like the Swedish ones, so I can.
Speaker 1: Very good.
Speaker 2: To find. I look forward.
Speaker 1: To trying that. No, I will absolutely
announce when I will be entering Sweden.
Speaker 2: Awesome.
Speaker 1: All right,
Magnus, thank you for the call. Yes. All right.
There is a very, very strong, strong phone call.
Let's go to Scipio from California, a very devoted
website member at David Pakman dot com. Scipio,
welcome to the show. What's on your mind?
Speaker 3: Sir David, Sir. Protector of the
realm, sir. Do I sound okay?
Speaker 1: You sound great.
Speaker 3: Okay. Awesome. So I have a
politics and a food question for you. Okay.
So we all know the McCarthy
debacle that kind of ended
with the speaker. How do you think that's going
to affect the Republican Party specifically
going into 2024, into the general.
Speaker 1: Election? It's too early
to say. The question is, can Republicans credibly
make the case that they are now united and stand
for something? Over the two years that they
are going to govern? Or does this rupture or
fracture get worse and worse and devolve into
more partizan infighting? It's we just we have
to wait and see. I don't think we know yet.
Speaker 3: Okay. Very good. Then the food
question I have for you is I'm Mexican-American,
so there's a lot of Mexican cuisine that I like.
But I know you're from Argentina. Is there
any Argentinean? I don't know if that's the
right way to put it. Is there any dishes from
Argentina that I should try or that you recommend?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. I mean,
there's there's just so many I mean,
Argentinean style empanadas would be very, very
high on the list. We're talking about oven baked,
not deep fried. You understand what I'm saying,
right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. We're not going to throw
those things in a deep fryer and just fry them
into submission. We're going to bake them.
The thing about a lot of Argentinean food is
that it really, It's from somewhere else. Like,
one of my favorite dishes is Milanese. But the
term Milan, Italy is literally in the name. It's
really an Italian dish. You know, the the thing
about Argentinean dishes, there's Argentinean
style pizza, which is its own thing. But pizza
is not, strictly speaking, Argentinean. You know,
there are so many things to try, but the oranges
of many of them are really in other countries.
Speaker 3: Wow. Okay. Well, I like
he said, oranges are great. Well,
thanks for taking my call. I really appreciate
it. I hope you have a good rest of your day.
Speaker 1: All right. Scipio from California,
always great to speak to you folks. That's all
I've got. I know there's 50 people who are
furious. I know it, I know it. But I can't
get to everybody every time. We will take
calls again, and I hope to speak to you soon.